[Musique]
cette photo de Jimmy Shin on voit Alex
onold qui est un grimpeur américain très
célèbre pour ses ascensions toujours
plus dangereuses de parois rocheuse
toujours plus haute ici on le voit à
Oman il termine une nouvelle voie dans
une forme du frissolo qui s'appelle le
psychobloc comme pour le frissolo il
n'est pas équipé de quelqu équipement de
protection que ce soit qui rend la
discipline évidemment extrêmement
dangereuse et extrêmement exigeante d'un
point de vue mental physique et
évidemment d'endurance ici il pratique
une forme du frissolo qui s'appelle le
Deep Water sowing ou psychobloc en
français dans cette forme de la
discipline le grimpeur ou la grimpeuse
doit poursuivre une voie aussi longtemps
que possible et lorsqu'elle lâche ou
qu'il lâche il ou elle doit se retrouver
dans une eau profonde d'où le terme deep
water soloing alexold il y a quelques
années a fait l'objet d'un documentaire
national géographique réalisé par
Elizabeth char vassarelli et jichine qui
a été récompensé par le SCAR du meilleur
documentaire en 2018 le nom de ce
documentaire fr
[Musique]
solo